the teacher that assaulted me got three
years probation and he like wasn't
allowed to teach for a little while it
was like that it was like not yeah
exactly my there was some sort of plea
bargain what happened was his therap or
his therapist his lawyer was uh my old
softball coach I used to play softball
with his daughter and yeah
exactly that's what I think but he lied
to my parents he said I think I can help
Annie by being on the side but he got
his guy off is what he did I can't
believe he just said he got his guy he
got his guy off
I can't believe the lawyer said he got
his guy I don't hate lawyers but there's
one I don't like a lot Jules I'm just
saying the first name hey Jules get your
ass back how's your daughter
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]